welcome to the panel session organized
by by ladies before we start just a
short announcement that we are having
social events and not everyone picked up
their bands so uh
find the time to do that before it
starts and with without further Ado I
will turn over to Paula
yeah hello everybody I'm I'm not hosting
the panel session but I will introduce
the how the panel session was born
so traditionally since last year there's
a Pilates panel and it's normally about
diversity topics and this time we ask
around the community and here you see
um the selfie the selfie from the from
the panelists
um Paloma who's a very engaged member of
the Pilates Berlin Community offered to
organize and they had just organized an
event in Palace Berlin about the book
hacking diversity so
um it's all it's all very fresh
and she's going to
show the book I think yeah so here's
Paloma
exactly she she has it here and I've
Been Told
it
she has it here even and she's going to
do something with Adam
um I've been told also that it will be a
panel discussion but it is a wish for
that everybody participates so Alina and
me will be
down with the mics and everybody is
encouraged to participate right away I
mean not not waiting until the end to
make um to make questions but
if you have an opinion if you have a
question just raise your hand Alina and
me will go to you and without more
here's Paloma and she will continue
thank you
um can you come up everyone
so I wanted to
[Music]
this is how I thought about how this
could be
um as Paula mentioned we did had a kind
of a book club session around this book
which
it was quite important for me to rethink
my own work as a
can you hear me well
cool around
my work on
diversity advocacy and I will be giving
away this book for the most upvoted
questions so keep your slido at hand we
will also use this Lido to ask you some
questions so you can Anonymous answer
some things I will also ask you to raise
your hands for some yes or no questions
and if you feel the urge to express her
opinion this should be a sort of like a
fishbowl style you are more than welcome
to join the this stage and in kind of
bigger stages this is a little more
awkward but I like the format a lot it
gives us all the chance to give us our
opinion and discuss further
and discuss further to me is a
interesting concept
this is why this panel is about is the
chance for us to connect with
communities from New York from Berlin
from other chart Partners in Germany to
reflect upon the work we're doing as
diversity advocates
everyone slide those in your hand so now
that I introduce the
what we will be doing here
and just a little synopsis on the book
If you don't know about it it is a dip
really academic research and
sociological research on what happened
and what the work on diversity
advocacy especially in hacker spaces in
between the some like I think 2005 to
2010 mostly in U.S but the end of the
book and I will give a spoiler is that
we will not save the world
and this is kind of oh
[Laughter]
but it's good to know it's when we know
our boundaries and this is what this
discussion is about is how much the work
we're doing is effective and what can we
do to improve it what our limitations
are and how can we work together with
others to improve that
so the slider question that I start for
you the origin is
when you think
don't think too much pop in when you
think about when you're here diversity
what's the first word that comes to your
mind
I open this slider here
and then I will ask you and that's the
last question before I come in starting
the talk is when someone presents to you
as a diversity Advocate what's the first
thing that your head label automatically
and please don't try to give me the
right answer this is not about the right
answer it's really uh understanding now
we're
bias and our understanding what they
says
oh do I have to change anything on the
slider
he might be able to just type something
as a question and then we can maybe take
it there
okay
nothing like technical issues at a
technical conference right
we have to be a little lighthearted with
that right like so while you're typing
now
um ask our lovely panelists to introduce
themselves
um yeah right oh I'm first hi all I'm
Erin Mikhail Staples I'm a senior
developer Community Advocate at label
Studio we're a labeling platform
um outside of that I'm a university
instructor as well as a stand-up
comedian so cool we keep it yeah but not
a technical person by trade Mike crafted
my teeth in journalism
that's really cool I'm a senior data
scientist working in Berlin
I work for relatively small startup I
mainly focus on the field of NLP
and use a lot of python
and yeah yeah
yeah
hi everyone I am Lynne I am a data
engineer at Mozilla I live in Brooklyn
New York
um
yeah that's like a shout out like
Brooklyn New York like
yeah New York high ladies chapter
yes I am uh so I've been at Mozilla for
two years now
um I started Mozilla after finishing my
Outreach internship which is a program
that helps encourage people from
underrepresented background to
participate more in the open source
Community
um yeah I've been with Mozilla for two
years A lot has changed since then a lot
that I've learned about the industry and
I hope that me being here and sharing
about my experience and observations can
help uncover some blind spots about the
industry so yeah grateful to be here
scientist and software developer at a
small company called inflict i o I used
to be a computational neuroscience PhD
working in Academia with statistical
modeling and data analysis
and I transitioned into Tech a couple of
years ago last year I gave a talk on
transitioning from science to data
science at pycon it's on YouTube so if
anybody wants to leave Academia you can
watch it
[Laughter]
um yeah and I'm a member of Pi ladies in
Berlin here and
[Music]
um yeah I'm a big fan of the palliative
community
thank you and um Paloma Olivera I work
for sauce Labs here in Berlin based as
an open source developer Advocate and
I'm also one of the co-organizers of
Pilates Berlin and just so we know our
questions I will read it out loud about
this diversity and a diversity Advocate
means to most of you
so I hear equal chances races
lgbtq y plus inclusion thick skin
diversity data separation underrated
oppression biodiversity inclusion
inclusion
gender diversity washing
not really diversity
um
whoa they must be brave
inclusion
inequality organized Civil Society voice
of representation
we are all different and that's awesome
rainbow resilience representative Equity
gender bias inclusion
so thinking a little bit
I would like to hear from the panel
um
if you think diversity for you what does
it mean the word today and where do you
think the problems of labeling diversity
brings to us
um maybe we can start with Hana
can you can you say it again when we
talk about diversity today especially in
the context of Open Source and
Technology
what do you think that mostly represent
and what do you think
um
are the problems of this regular broad
understanding where we should be dealing
with
you mean like what what's the um the
current problem with diversity in open
source or in Tech in general
um
I think it's definitely
um a problem with gender but also like
with other underrepresented groups like
every self-identified under represented
group like sexual orientation
um ethnicity race
um
uh yeah like
um socio-economic economical background
and there are like so many minorities
which are not represented in open source
and also if you think of like a very
European centristic and North America is
very represented but like where's the
rest of the world
um I think it's a very broad topic
um yeah and a lot to do and there's a
talk by modern Westerman tomorrow on
that so I think it's like
um definitely a topic where you can give
a talk about so it's difficult to to say
like in two sentences
and Lynn in your experience and or from
your personal context where do you think
lies the issues of saying diversity
today
okay from my experience
so to me diversity
is about Freedom it's about feeling safe
enough in an environment so that I can
fully Express who I am without being
scared of oh like
because I am or I am the minority if I
fully show up
as who I am will that be a safe thing
will that hurt my career in any way
would that hurt my social capital in any
way
and
to reflect um back in my own experience
um
when I first joined the tech industry
and I I don't have a University degree
so not only I look different than a lot
of my colleagues I also come from a
different social economic background
so in the beginning I had to learn
like how to behave the right way how to
act the right way
how can I
use the right languages so a lot of my
colleagues are like very well educated
so the language they use I'm some of
some of them I'm not super familiar with
so there's like a whole process of me
learning how to fit in right
um
and but that was like I was happy to do
all of that work because I felt lucky I
felt lucky that I made it in
um but then I I spoke with a colleague
of mine that I really really respected
um and I shared my enthusiasm about oh
like I like I'm so happy to be here like
by me breaking in the industry I could
like open doors for more people to
Andrea from me who looked like me who
experience life the same way I do
but that person told me that Lynn in the
beginning you should just focus on your
like technical work because you already
look so different than the rest of the
people here you in a way subconsciously
people already have a certain bias
against you so if you want to help other
people who are like you first proof your
worth by showing your technical ability
and then once you have once you move up
the ladder you use that power to drive
the initiative forward
and
and that made a lot of sense to me when
she said that um
but in a way it's also a sad thing that
I have to
shut down a part of who I am a part of
me that I'm really proud of just so
I can help things move forward and it is
a dilemma that I still have to face to
this day so diversity again back to what
I said earlier it's about freedom and
the safety to ex
to feel free
I want to go back to that topic because
I think you bring a lot of things that
we can problematize in a
lot of topics oh no I want to go back to
that
but just before I would like to hear
Doreen and there is murdering opinion
about uh where do you think it lies the
main issues of diversity today not
becoming a buzzword and really having a
meaning to understand what we're doing
here
yes I think the the problem is that some
wear different stands on how people
think we are like what the current state
is that some people think it's still a
huge problem and some people think it's
kind of solved already so some people
say oh we don't really need to pay
attention anymore in Germany because
theoretically females have the same
rights as men
but is that really the case like it's
just I think combining
the different viewpoints and like going
over the secretion over and over again
and realizing oh there's a lot of work
that still needs to be done in order for
people to feel safe so that like a
minority group doesn't have to prove
itself more than other people do because
that's not fair nobody should say you
have to prove yourself more just because
you're a minority
thus and I think there is a lot of work
still to be done for everybody to be
equal and also the main issue as you
reference is that we're now on the same
page as where the issues lie and also
like how far we still have to go
to go back and unpack a lot of that
yeah
oh yeah for everybody else we got a clap
of like
[Applause]
and there we from your perspective from
your background and experience is where
do you think to you like the main issues
of tackling diversity lies today we make
a lot of assumptions and I think there's
the whole thing you know don't make
assumptions it's making an ass out of
you and me
um
but to kind of
iterate on that I am a very white I am
white we're just going to say that like
it is I mean that's pretty obvious guys
um I'm a white heteronormative passing
neurodiverse individual I am a queer
woman and that being said it puts me in
a situation
where I'm very fortunate to have had
privileges to place me where I'm at
today but
it's not perfect my colleagues and I
have been at my last role specifically I
was making 25 000 less than my male
colleague with the same amount of
experience on paper and we shared offer
letters
and that sucked and it took three and a
half months
to get that salary equity on par
and things like that and I will even
commend those of you in this room
this is that most empty I've seen this
room in any talk
we don't want to talk about diversity
it's uncomfortable
and sometimes I don't even feel like I'm
the right person to talk about it it's a
white you know heteronormative passing
female
but how many times we referred to it as
having enough of a certain quota in our
organization or
you know they're great at it if only
they were a female
If Only They were a person of color I
would love to invite them
when did it just become this is the
right person for the job and how are we
extending an arm to the opportunities
and this is like getting past that and I
think that's what we need to start
thinking about
[Applause]
thank you
wondering what should we tackle first
can I like because I had um I really
enjoyed what Lynn said about the freedom
to be yourself and I think that we say
that explicitly like how many times have
we all been in a workplace
that they're like oh it's great these
people are wonderful it's free to be me
um and then it's like just kidding
but if that's okay unless anybody wants
to take it another Direction
no yeah this is a um
so I'm formulating a directly question
for that first to unravel that and um
what we were speaking before and
I was wondering
like afford this table to share with
everyone
um
if we
specifically that case that being
brought like if you are on your
workspace and people say what does it
means when someone say you should prove
yourself
is very technical before and I will
speak some things that come to my mind
why this is problematic first of all it
is in the hierarchy and that's really
clear in open source which is my main
area
um although we know we depend on an
ecosystem and not just in the technical
part there is a gigantic difference in
the recognition of people that are more
technical than the others gigantic is
you do not even speak about it this is
how automatically we think
so that's you're being judged by how
you're delivering although if you're a
software engineer for example how do you
rate someone a senior
I think this is a common issue in the
industry that you cannot compare to
seniors in two different places and two
different uh
place so it's like you have to prove
you're doing your work right what what
does it mean so that's the first
question that it comes to my mind and
the second like uh that would like to
for you both for you for you all to
problematize this on top of that so
that's problem what does it means that I
have to prove myself on my work and why
is that different than
fostering a place that brings benefits
to everyone for being a safe space
maybe Doreen would you like to put some
thoughts yeah so for the senior Junior
kind of thing
and Technical expertise expertise
especially so in order to or what
seniors should do in my opinion is
Mentor other people to learn to be good
at their job to help them out if their
problems but that's not necessarily what
people get promoted for the same for
managing positions so I think often in
fact people get promoted for oh they
have written the most code let's promote
them but that's not really what the
qualities that you might need in like a
senior position because it's more about
empathy and helping others than helping
yourself succeed in a way
yep so that's my take on it
and mean would you like to like speak
more and how that maybe
how reflected on that that was your
personal experience that reflected upon
and what is the yeah what is the
and 31 cover all the issues surrounding
that possible because that that's an
opinion it's a valid opinion you should
focus on that but why is that different
than taking care of the environment the
space and bringing others up
yeah
um
I think at the time when I was given
that advice I was so new to the industry
excuse me
that I didn't really think whether or
not
that was a good advice to follow
and should I but like since like
like work in general like being at work
like work is already
complex environment to navigate and I
feel like for all of us not just you
know only for people of color people
from marginalized communities
so there are so many things that play
there and so in a way like me being
given that advice oh I should just focus
on your like technical uh
work that's like that helps simplify the
process for me in a bit
um but then I realized that
my work
is not divorced from who I am if you
know what I mean like I have to feel
safe show enough for me
to
like be successful to feel like
like I can learn
so I can't just like shut down a part of
me and be like okay I'm just gonna like
code program like show up in meetings
like cold face you know like the rest of
my colleagues or like that's not
possible for me in order for me to
to
learn and to improve my like technically
and like from like Junior to senior I
need
to be able to show up fully so that play
some examples that I can think of is
that I am from Vietnam and it is a very
collectivist culture and
there's like certain hierarchies in like
the social
um
the social environment so in general I
would feel like I feel less comfortable
with speaking just for the sake of
speaking in meetings for example or like
I've I I'm usually more reserved it's
not because I don't have anything to say
it's more that I respect the people in
the room and I want to hear everyone and
there's a saying in like Vietnamese
culture is that you should listen to the
air
so when someone speaks to you listen to
what they say but also to the air to
like look for if there's like more
layers to what they're trying to to like
um convey to you
um
but then because I work for a U.S
because I work for Mozilla which is a
U.S heavy company
in a way I feel like
that side of me is not really welcome
um
so I have to force myself to be like the
rest of my Western colleagues
and
and a lot of days I feel like but
I was hired because people told me that
your diversity is your strength we want
people with your experience we want your
perspective but then I have to shut down
who I am just so I can move up the
ladder
then then what's the point like is that
really my strength if I have to erase my
identity
um
so
if they if my company wants me to
succeed if the industry wants me to
succeed
they can't tell me just focus on your
technical ability
they have to
and I don't know the right answer yet
this is a hard question to answer but
they have to show me that it's safe for
me to be who I am and like in whatever
capacity you show up we will try to help
you succeed because we've been doing
that for the majority of the people in
the industry we can do the same for you
that was really cool thank you yeah for
sharing oh yeah also like to maybe touch
up on that for years maybe also you take
a lot of effort into trying to fit in
and that kind of takes away energy that
you can put into your work mentally
exhausting yeah very taxing work every
day there's like that's the invisible
work that people talk about when they
speak about people uh caller being in
like a white majority space there's a
lot of work that like people don't know
and we're not doing the same amount of
work
yeah okay thank you
this brings me to um a thought that is
so we speak a lot about diversity and I
think many people are already kind of
tired to hear
diversity again or it's like what's the
point of it and quoting some things uh
heard
um
like well if we already achieved 30 of
women in this space why do we still need
to do more there's so much to be done so
but
really like a
should we stop talking about it and we
are still talking about it why so
um
why is it still needed to reinforce that
but if we're having pushbacks what we
are doing wrong or what should we be
doing to match the speech and the
ideology of we need to stand up for
diversity
but you need to feed in
like if we're talking about diversity
how we're speaking about it but what
changes we need to do to match and
create the safe space that Lena was
talking about
um yeah right oh wow um
that's like a hard like um I think it's
a hard one intentionally
um
I've been the only female at a company
before
um
I am currently
uh my immediate team is a team of two
I'm the only female on that team it's a
team of twos I feel like that's it also
I just binary gender which I don't like
doing either so it's another weird thing
but
um
we need to have the uncomfortable icky
conversations and even the ones that
make you want to squirm in your chair a
little bit myself included no one's
perfect you don't there's no bat in 100
at diversity like
there's
and I think that starts and we have to
keep having this conversation for
a couple of reasons one
y'all look around there's empty seats
here
if this was a true priority we'd see
this room packed
um
I think the other thing is we're still
having experiences time and time again
of
people not feeling welcome
um if you're a woman in the room how
many times you've been asked to take
notes
or because I'm Aaron that's a gender
neutral name in many parts of the world
um someone asked for my receptionist
once or I asked if I was a receptionist
for Aaron once I was like that was
pretty cool
um it's instances like this that we just
don't seem to take seriously anymore and
sure we hit a quota but like what the
what is the quota like that's what did
that achieve
it doesn't change the systems
have any takes on that Hannah
um yes
um
I think
to think about diversity is also very
important because
you really have to think about your own
prejudices and biases and
I think we all have them
um me included of course and I was just
thinking about a friend who told me that
she was like asked by a female Project
Lead to
um that she should like peer program
more with her colleagues because she
could like maybe improve and she was all
she was actually better than them so she
was there like
um lead and um
and it's I think and I think maybe it
didn't even occur to her that um she
maybe she could like um why why would
she like propose this to her so and I
think this is like something which
happens often and might happen to
everybody
and yeah I think it's it's
yeah it's it's very important to think
about that
yeah
um
I want to do an exercise with our
audience and ask you to maybe close your
eyes for you to really give the opinion
that you really have and I hope the
cameras are not recording the public for
that
and the question is sorry for now close
your eyes just so make sure you're not
judging anyone around this just just the
panelists will judge you no I'm kidding
we cannot actually sanctify everyone but
um
if someone spent part of their job your
colleagues talking about issues around
diversity
do you judge them is that part of you
that thinks oh damn are they coming with
that again instead of doing their job I
mean do you have any bad judgment and
prejudices toward that person please
raise your hands if yes
thank you
um
yeah and the last question please keep
your eyes closed again do you think that
this person spending their time
um thinking about this kind of efforts
which is extra work do affect their
career path
thank you I really appreciate you all
can go back to the panel to problematize
a little bit more of that so those are
the discussions we should be having so
by one hand we know this is no-brainer
it is an issue it's a current issue
we're not equal there are many
difference in this space we still live
under
patriarchy capitalist system which
implies a lot of the systemic issues
that we face
that's not like a questionable by the
other hand there is a friction in
between speech
social justice push to improve and how
we do our
day by day or daily jobs
the question is
um places like Pilates which is what
we're here to talk about we try to
tackle those issues but we have we know
about it and this book is much about it
that we cannot solve all the issues
especially that the big companies or the
technology that is so
permissive in our daily lives brings
also has issues
I would like to hear you from your
experience being part of Pi ladies and
other advocacy programs
which kind of tactics have you been
using to try to balance this very
unbalanced Society wherein
maybe Hannah we can start with you
and you mean what like the Pilates did
to
um help overcome do you think that is a
interesting
um tactic or action that you personally
did or saw that Pilates helped in this
problematic system
and for me it was like really really
important when I was transitioning from
Academia to Tech to be part of this
community is also of women in machine
learning and data science which was also
a Meetup I went to and yeah Pilates of
course and to meet other women in Tech
who told me that you can do it I could
do I can do it so you can do it too it
was like really empowering for me
it's just 2B like surrounded by women so
because in my day-to-day work in my team
I'm the only woman
currently and yeah it's like it's I
think something like every woman and in
techno was like how it feels and it if
you feel a bit alienated if you're like
the only woman yeah
and then you besides of Pi lady you
mention how to reach a program which if
you don't know it's one of the main and
most non-recognized programs that gives
a paid three months internship for
people to start contributing to open
source
it's really targeting unrepresented
people people that are not represented
in this space
um so how in your experience of which
art besides of the program itself that
launched your career in Tech
is there any other
um action that you would like to mention
um
any other actions from this group if
they're Pi ladies or that was
fundamental for you
um
yeah
so okay so in the tech industry besides
outreaching
um
and So currently I'm doing a lot of like
mentorship work to
people from underprivileged backgrounds
in my home country Vietnam
and um what I've observed so far is that
like too late really back to your
question of like what kind of tactics
are they that can be helpful
um
now that I'm in a different social
economic background my Social Circle is
different now the people hang out with
are not people from blue collar or like
pink color feels like before
um the conversations have changed a lot
of that
and this is me at Mid end that like okay
I don't have a lot to relate to the
people that I eat
like not really but I don't have a lot
of like similar daily life experiences
to the people that I want to help
anymore and
um
that kind of
helps me realize that
okay so in order to be
to be a helpful and effective advocate
for diversity
and through only me trying to do this
work with the with the communities that
they that need help but like I am not
part of them anymore
is that this this work is hard work it
is
like diversity efficacy is hard work
it's not just intellectually challenging
it is emotionally psychologically and
spiritually challenging
because especially if you're doing good
work right when people feel that they
can trust you people from under
um represented communities they will
come out for the woodwork in a way and
tell you their experience because they
trust that you could help them
and these things are usually are not the
things that are covered in books or like
scholarly articles or
what have you so you are asked to
provide safe space for them and also
figure out a way to help them and that's
a lot for for someone to bear so I guess
what I'm trying to say here is that
like
like I have a lot of empathy and respect
for people who are doing this work I am
not that actively
um
it's not like my job title
but I can see like the work that people
are doing and I I just I said please be
kind on yourself like take care of
yourself in order to to help the people
you want to help you have to help
yourself first give yourself the space
the time the emotional safety that you
need so that you can provide that for
others
uh so that's like one tactic that people
could use like take care of yourself
everyone it's really hard work
during you have
like do you have
sure I'm kind of paying attention to
this lighter but yeah
but wait wait microphone go
my check
um because I thought it was so
interesting what Jesus said about um she
maybe I got it wrong but do you feel
like you're not being authentic because
you don't have the same background
anymore as the people that you're
coaching right now because you did have
it in the past and you don't have I feel
like you don't have to prove yourself
now to be
um you know authentic to help them
because now you maybe moved up from your
previous background or something that
doesn't mean you still haven't
experienced that so why why do you feel
like right now you don't associate
yourself with the same people you did
before and it felt like you're kind of
like not justifying it but you made it a
point that you're not in that group
anymore so it feels difficult to help
those people because you
I don't know it was for me it's it's
hard to understand why you made it a
point but do you feel like you're not a
part of that anymore
um it doesn't make sense yeah no that
made total sense I think excuse me
um and I feel like if you're an
immigrant or if you're like a minority
and like major minority in any kind of
environment you can relate to this
feeling that you don't really belong
anywhere
so
so right now if you ask me oh are you
part of the elite the coastal Elite like
how like um there's a lot of like talks
about that in the U.S media no I'm not
I'm not I don't have a University degree
I make Tech money yes but does that mean
that I'm part of the group because in
order to feel like I'm part of the group
I have to
feel like people already upset me for
who I am yet and that is not the case
right now unfortunately
and what I meant earlier
um
so I'm helping people from from like
underprivileged backgrounds in Vietnam
right they would come to me with
complaints about they can't even afford
to
till they put Lane food on their table
for like just one meal they can't even
do that I'm not in that position anymore
or they would come and tell me about
stuff that related to like their family
dramas and all of that I now live in a
in the U.S
and like if you're not familiar excuse
me I don't know can I
well thank you so much
um
so Vietnam uh like in the last century
there was like Vietnam was in constant
Wars with like very big countries so the
half of my family were killed in the
Vietnam War
so there's a lot of like
intergenerational dramas that happened
um that that you can't really escape and
that manifests as addiction mental
health issues
poverty all of that stuff
when I was living back in Vietnam that
was the stuff that I have to do like
face with lately I can't just focus on
what I want to focus I have to also take
care of those other things my family my
daily responsibilities
but now I don't have to deal with that
anymore
so when people come to me and be like oh
oh that sucks well it isn't that I can't
be like yeah I know I'm going through
the same thing because I'm not
um
so in order for me to be able to relate
and like provide safe space for them I
have to forget my current reality that
I'm living comfortably now you know like
uh in like a developed country and
in a way re-traumatized myself pull me
back to the past so that I can be in the
same space with them without making it
look like I'm judging them or just
trying to
to provide empty ears if that makes
sense
so that is hard work
I I made it out but now I have to go
back to the old situation because I want
to be there fully for the people that
I'm helping
so back to your question do I feel like
do I'm not identify with that uh
to with my past anymore
I think it's a good thing that I don't
identify with that person anymore but
that
but I also don't identify with the
current reality anymore so I'm in limbo
and this is the reality of a lot of
people
in the world right now we don't fully
feel like we belong anywhere
and and back to the freedom to express
who we are right that doesn't have to be
a bad thing us not fitting in us not
fitting in anywhere doesn't have to be a
bad thing
if we if we can if I can feel safe not
belong in anywhere then I don't have to
try to fit in so much
anywhere anymore and that gives me the
energy to do the things that I really
care about
um I don't know if that will answer your
questions
I mean places like Berlin in New York
specifically where Berlin the last time
I checked we had a 30 that are not from
Germany living in the city that adds on
top of diversity which issue
like when companies say we are a diverse
company they mean they want to fill in a
gender gap which is woman and mostly
white woman
so diversity can be quite tricky for in
Berlin or New York that you have 30
people that come from such a diverse
background many people coming from
places running from Wars or a refugee
that's super complicated
um psychologically speaking
it is hard to address so
um drain and airing like which things do
you think that both Berlin and New York
chapters are doing that you think
kind of help
to bring diversity which is this big
bucket into helping people improve their
lives especially getting into technology
yeah
do you want to go first sure
um
I think right now in New York
um specifically in Pilates um one of the
organizers that does a lot of the groups
is really involved in like the sober
movement
um how many people have like gone to a
tech Meetup at a bar like that's kind of
been the common quid pro Crow and I do
know that the New York Chapter is really
prioritizing making sure that events are
sober events in many times which I think
is very important we don't talk about
that enough
um other things that I've seen happening
specifically in New York
um and just not in the pie ladies
chapter but in other groups um New York
didn't get a very bad rap everybody if
you missed the whole thing about the
wing and the white woman girl boss thing
um that was the whole thing in New York
and that was a huge part of many women
in Tech were involved through the wing
or which was a huge huge thing and I
mean I got a scholarship together and it
was a it was a thing like for those of
you who weren't or who aren't aware the
wing was a co-working space targeting
women specifically and it had the pink
branding and the the cute coffee cups
and the instagrammable workspace but not
surprisingly targeted primarily white
women and they found out later that they
were stealing work from interns and not
paying their employees fairly and many
service workers were service workers of
color rather than actually representing
a more realistic population of the world
and when we think about things it's
um really being aware of like what
stories are getting told and elevated
and why
I think the other thing are you telling
it to make yourself seem cool and
diverse are you telling it because it's
a story told and putting on my former
journalist hat here
um that's an editorial discretion
decision
which outlines kind of the values and
ethics of the companies in the group
that you're organizing with
for the Berlin chapter so I think we all
try to do is create safe spaces and also
create a sense of community somehow but
it is also true that in the Berlin
chapter for example we are also
predominantly white and I think we can
also do a lot better like also for for
all kinds of diversity also for people
with disabilities for example
or mothers like we recently started
talking more about what if we want child
care for example if people want to bring
their kids and stuff in the evening
um
so I think
we do some stuff and we try
but we can also there are a lot more
things we can do and it's also
like if anybody of you wants to join
pilates at some point we need help and
we need more diverse people as well we
need people with different views and
opinions to like bring in these ideas
and also say hey have you thought about
this group or do we really want to like
create a safe space for uh these people
now so I think I think one thing I liked
here is like the we're all still working
we're all works in progress
there's always there's something I could
be doing better probably every day every
minute like we're all works in progress
and don't
be afraid to do things perfectly and I
think going back to tactics to kind of
bounce off one thing and it's maybe a
pet peeve of mine is I am and I will
take the notes and I hate being called
the secretary in a meeting and coming
from a non-technical background
um and they were like oh you'll learn to
code because you took notes on the
meeting and I'm like no I do not need to
remember your follow-up or your coffee
order I don't care sorry can't even
remember my own but if you're looking
for a simple tactic
take the notes dudes sorry or don't or
like pass it around pass the Baton
around who takes the notes in the
meeting sure Google doc
sorry let's pet peeve
tactics that are pet peeves gosh we are
about six minutes to one days and we
have
a really amazing start popping up
questions
um
before addressing at least a few of them
um I would like to ask you to join pie
ladies it's
um not a place for women it is a place
to improve the world around us and that
support more women's to have their
voices in the spaces and Leadership that
means we do need allies analyzes the
other thing that we need to talk more if
you don't know how to start par ladies
Berlin in our GitHub repository we are
adding resources for self-education so
you can start understanding better what
are all those discussions about and this
is the first step you're educating
yourself and understanding your own bias
and where to get started because this
has been there's a lot of good
documentation out there
um and interesting I just want to point
it out that although I think everyone in
this panel a big part of our careers is
due to this community work
um
part of if we'd like a visual percentage
probably more than half of the people do
think when we were voting that it is
bad for your career to be involved with
advocacy with diversity advocacy
so this is an interesting to think right
like although I depend my career on it
there's some part of me that things that
that real ruins my career that's
interesting the other part is that we do
have some on buyers involved when you
think about diversity as a bad thing
although we all recognize that that's a
very systemic issue
so a lot of open to discussion I would
like to keep those questions and work on
it at least in the Berlin chapter maybe
we can start a discussion I've read it
or some point I will point it out at
select because the questions are great I
will
put in the most voted ones for you to
quickly put your thoughts it is how do
you handle the Dilemma of not always
wanting to be the one in interviews
presentations Etc versus is still
encouraging fellow woman to join the
industry
so I believe this is a question about
like um you don't want to be talking
about it but you still want to advocate
for other women
recommend someone
yeah like if you know someone's really
passionate about it recommend someone
else
I've done that I've like been like past
the mic um
or um write a note and send it to your
male colleagues if you don't feel
comfortable I've done that before too
I've been like tired of answering this
dumb question can you please
pass it but 101 I think is also good so
you don't have to publicly sit on a
stage and talk about stuff you can
one-on-one talk to people as well like
you can be an ally in private
what can I do as a white male in the
tech industry to make you feel like you
belong you can be yourself and enable
you to continue the dialogue that's a
lovely question
thank you
well I can say for like my my personal
manager is
very heavy Advocate and what he does is
like using his privilege to make sure
for example everyone in the team has the
same payment equal payment for example
even your the transparency is not
even if it the transparency salary is
not part of the company politics he
makes sure without saying that everyone
is equal and having the same
opportunities so using your privilege is
a good way to get started and offering
the space for the others to have the
voice so providing the spotlight for
someone that needs to have their voice
up and we talk a lot about sponsorship
it's a term that goes around a lot
during the diversity Advocate
side though
not just Mentor but the cherry and bring
the people into the table to talk this
is the best thing you can do use your
privilege can I yeah on this
um because I also so I think this is
super important but also speaking up if
you see something that's going wrong so
an easy example is like people being cat
called on street for example like if
women can't really say anything about it
because you will just get like really
bad responses back but men can and like
in a lot of settings where things are
happening that are not right if you see
something like that say it because as a
cisman you have more Authority
to say something against other CIS men
yeah like that was it even happens in
the workplace like you know that was
doreen's idea like it was really badass
like we should recommend her like next
time
yeah um I also wanted to share something
so uh when I first uh like joined
Mozilla so my last name is win it's a
very common Vietnamese last name and
g-u-y-e-n
it's very common but it's very hard to
pronounce
um and when I was introduced in a team
meeting oh hey Lee we just hired Lin
which is my first name and then my last
name was left out because people
couldn't pronounce it so the person who
introduced me and didn't really say it
um compare that to another team meeting
uh also my first time showing up at that
meeting the person who led that meeting
um
like two days before the meeting email
me a long email explaining okay this is
the research that I've done to figure
out how to pronounce your last name I've
seen like these two YouTube videos are
you from the North or are you from the
south
differently than the North and all of
that and that to me
shows a genuine curiosity about where
I'm from who I am and my identity and
like back to the point we said earlier
right it's not about getting it right
it's about making a safe space And by
you just I guess
just be curious just like if there's
someone at your company on your team
that's like from a minority background
go talk to them ask them about who they
are like their name their Hobbies their
interests their culture everything like
you should really show them that you're
interested in them and you want them to
be here in this space and you want to do
whatever possible to make them feel like
they're part of the group
then that to me is
it's the best way that you could could
do as a white male as the majority right
just be curious in in who I am in like
who your teammate is
um but yeah
oh the hour is over
I'm very sad about that but I want to
appreciate a lot thank you to Pano for
sharing your personal stories this is a
super valid
um and the person also thank you a lot
thank you everyone for being in the
space I believe that you're interested
on and this is super valuable as well
thank you the organization for giving us
the spotlight and the space to have
those discussions and I hope we can
follow through with it and thank you for
for doing the panel with us and
preparing everything that you did an
amazing job a lot of invisible work yeah
yeah
and please
um
the person who wrote the question will
get this book so look for me if you
don't want to be here right now look for
me I have the book the person who wrote
what can I do as a white male in the
attack industry to make you feel you
belong you can be yourself and enable
you to continue the dialogue you got a
book
[Applause]